completed the majority of the crew
exchanges
as we all know this call came in at 4 45
this morning and crews responded from
not only here in the mount charleston
fire protection district but also the
las vegas valleys we have crews from
clark county fire department the city of
las vegas fire department who actually
did the majority of the extinguishment
in coordination with
the mount charleston fire protection
district we have nevada or excuse me the
u.s forest service and also blm on scene
so clark county is in the process of
exchanging the city of las vegas fire
crews to send them back to the city of
las vegas
so they can go back to return to their
fire stations
currently where we are in the operation
we're in what we call the overhaul
stage where we're trying to extinguish
any hidden fires that are just
smoldering as you can see in this from
the structure behind me there's a
there's light white smoke coming off of
it which is primarily a result of hidden
fires that we have yet to be able to
extinguish because we have not gone
inside the structure yet our plan of
operation from this point forward we
just backed in
clark county fire department truck 11.
they actually normally work
in the city of las vegas
on the las vegas strip but we call them
up here to do a an operation on the roof
our plan is to bring an excavator up
here with the assistance of public works
we're going to start peeling back the
roof structure which is the primary
hazard for firefighters right now
because it has collapsed in on the
building so we're going to peel that
back and then probably use the aerial or
the truck company
to get above
the structure and extinguish any fires
that we can that we can see from that
vantage point so that's our current
operation in addition to uh the
investigation is currently underway we
believe we have uh the origin uh
isolated to a specific area in the
vicinity of the dining room but causes
yet to be determined and it will
probably be quite some time they're in
the process of doing what we call
digging out the fire that's where they
remove all the debris from on top of
where it probably started so they can
identify exactly what the source was if
possible
that's where we are with the current
operation
are firefighters right now able to
take all the items out of the building
like you said without even with the
hazard that the
roof is unstable
we're not doing that in the majority of
the building we've been able to do that
and where we think the origin is because
whatever roof structure was on it
completely burned off which is kind of
what gives you know gives us an idea of
where it started where the most damage
is you know we're burned the longest and
the hottest that's where we start our
focus and we think we have that
identified and there's no roof structure
on top it's all it all burned off
so they were able to pull whatever fell
fell in pull that out and now they have
basically open sky above their heads so
it's a safe investigation and that's
still we're still talking about the
dining room vicinity area the vicinity
i'm going to say the vicinity of the
dining area where it was originally as
crews arrived on scene
again mount charleston fire protection
district was crews were first to arrive
on scene and they reported heavy fire in
the vicinity of the dining area can you
tell me about the weather the light rain
isn't making a difference at all or are
you guys expecting heavier rain
currently
the rain is not having an impact if it
was heavier rain and if it was earlier
in the incident that would assist us
with any embers you know that we're
going up into the sky and possibly
falling on either you know the dry
timber up here or people's homes
but earlier this morning the weather was
it was more clear and sunny when the
fire started
and so currently with this light drizzle
it's not having an impact one way or the
other
can you talk about how important it was
to get on this fire early and the
dangers that came with us and who should
be credited for
keeping it to this one structure
honestly uh it's a it was a joint effort
i'll say again that the city of las
vegas fire department because of their
vicinity in the las vegas valley you
know they cover the majority of the
northwest where clark county units cover
the majority of the south end of town
and east ends of town
the city units were primarily here first
we did have mount charleston fire
protection district who launched an
early attack to put water on the fire
and try to keep it from growing as best
they could but a fire like this really
requires a lot of resources and we have
what's called automatic aid agreements
where we all help each other out
automatically so when a call comes in
our our central dispatch center just
sends whatever the closest resources are
and for this particular incident the
majority of those resources were the
city of las vegas could have been worse
though with up here in this terrain
absolutely if we didn't get water on the
fire i think you know that it's very
likely that it could have spread to some
of these adjacent lodges and you can see
all the adjacent lodges around here have
pine trees you know and it only takes
one pine tree for another pine tree and
then another you know pretty soon we
could have potentially had you know a
large forest fire
can you talk about
the progression of a fire inside of a
structure varies depending on the
structure type uh this particular
structure is not if the majority of it
is what we call heavy timber
construction
a lodge um so it's it's old pine you
know logs etc stacked on top of each
other those don't burn as fast as a
typical what we call a lightweight
structure that like our homes in las
vegas so they don't necessarily they
don't burn as fast but they do put off a
lot of radiant heat you know and all the
structures around it are pretty much log
homes and log structures you know so
they're not necessary they're not as
success susceptible to
um radiant heat as a lightweight
structure
but the pine trees are you know the pine
trees are very susceptible and i i i
expect there was a lot of pine tree
clearing around the lodge as is required
generally you know make sure you keep
your pine trees away from the homes so
it doesn't you know any house fire
doesn't spread to the pine trees and
vice versa pine tree fires don't spread
to the houses you know so
um
again this was a great effort by all
parties involved all departments that
responded you know we always work well
together and this is another example of
where we were able to get up here
quickly you know respond from town get
up here quickly and keep this fire from
extending
have you had an opportunity
i have not but we are in contact with
the with the property owners
when you saw the fire
was there any concern
from you about being able to get all the
trucks up here with the elevation the
weather
the winding roads any
the answer to that is no and the reason
is because we we again we have a close
relationship with with the departments
that are up here
not only the mount charleston fire
protection district district but also
u.s forest service so this wouldn't this
isn't our first time coming up here
and here we have the city of las vegas
truck company that's departing and
heading back to back to vegas
no injuries right
there
we still have not been able to search
the interior of the structure for
potential victims or fatalities
we have
very low degree of suspicion that that
there was ever anybody in there there's
no reported persons lost
well what i think what would have made
this more challenging for us
uh is if the roads were wet and icy you
know then we have a high degree of
concern for fire trucks coming from las
vegas who aren't equipped you know to
drive on icy roads because that's not
necessarily what we do on a regular
basis so our our response would have
maybe been a little bit delayed but more
than likely if there was snow piled on
all these trees you know that would have
lowered our concern for you know
extension into the forest
and also adjacent homes if their
rooftops are covered in snow
that that lessens the degree of concern
for fire extension
are you willing to speculate at all on
potential causes like
you know what what's on the table
i can't speculate because there's so
many different you know possibilities uh
it could be electrical it could be
a cooking thing it could be
uh
arson it could be a lot of things you
know um so it's really impossible to
speculate and it's not fair to do so
how much longer do you think the road
will stay closed a few more hours or
throughout the rest of the day
now i think that it'll probably be an
hour or two more hours i would assume
because we have the majority of our
resources
out
that we don't need and the majority of
the resources that we do need or in you
know i guess probably our biggest
concern
um i'm pretty sure they're letting
homeowners pass both directions you know
our biggest concern is
we don't need people coming up here and
jamming up the roads just to see what
happened you know and so we may continue
just blocking people from coming up here
for recreational purposes for quite some
time
thank you what do you think
tell my wife
it's really hard to say i would guess a
few days
a few days before we know and it will be
probably longer before we release that
information
thank you thank you